toujours plein d'entrain pour aller
travailler fidji prend son rôle très à
coeur
aujourd'hui sur le camp militaire de ben
séance d'entraînement après qu'un
collègue est posée différents produits
s'est elle de jouer
allez on y va pas bouger tu attends une
minute alors tu cherches il ne faut pas
plus de quelques minutes à la malinoise
pour marquer l'emplacement voilà si
fidji est aussi enthousiaste c'est parce
que pour elle il s'agit d'un jeu et
pourtant son travail est très sérieux
elle détecte les produits utilisés lors
d'un incendie criminel
alcool à brûler white spirit ou essence
rien n'échappe à son flair quel que soit
leur état
il ya un produit qui a été brûlé un
produit qui a terrassé à l'eau est un
produit qui est resté nature pourquoi
ces trois états parce que quand on a mis
le feu ben les produits ont été brûlées
donc ce qui altère et ce qu'ils changent
leurs odeurs et sur le causse la
composition quand les pompiers sont
arrivés ça a été lavé donc pour
apprendre le chien a travaillé sur du
produit brûlé sur du produit la lave et
suite à une intervention des pompiers et
sur la matière a natural poissy trouver
le produit qui n'a pas encore été brûlés
comme elle ils sont une dizaine dans le
pays
une spécialité unique en ile de france
qui votent à fidji des opérations
régulières
cette année elle a participé à 19
interventions avec son maître une équipe
complices car la chienne de 7 ans a
parfois ses humeurs yves est l'un des
rares à pouvoir l'amadouer et surtout la
comprendre ouf
ce qui veut dire papa car oui c'est mon
chien oui je travaille avec elle c'est
pas communauté de travail parce que si
on utilise notre chien que comme un
outil de travail bas moment donné ça va
pas marre ça va pas aller donc c'est
vraiment le binôme
je travaille avec elle j interprète en
langage humain ce que ce que le chef ne
donne en langage un langage chien je
dirais elle me donne des indices en
chien moi je les traduis en langage
humain pour que mes collègues puisse
interpréter et puisse avancer sur
l'heureux sur leur zone
un véritable duo formé pendant 14
semaines à gramat au centre national
d'instruction cynophile de la
gendarmerie iv fidji ont été accordées
selon leur caractère ne pas mettre un
chien qui va être hyper speed 1 m qui va
être calme et l' inverse
donc on essaie d'équilibrer sur les
caractères on à la seule administration
à le faire ça marche pas mal du tout du
début de mission jusqu'à la fin de
mission il faut qu'à travail avec la
même motif de motivation est le même le
même entrain un chien qui au bout d'une
minute de travail va tout laisser tomber
parce qu'il en a marre
nous ne nous intéressera pas donc le jeu
ça peut s'apprendre un chien la
persévérance au jeu c'est inné soyez là
soit il l'a pas une mission qui se
termine toujours par une récompense un
moment de jeu avec son maître fidji
devrait servir encore jusqu'à ses 12 ans
elle aura ensuite droit à une retraite
bien méritée la gendarmerie recherche
toujours des chiens pour renforcer son
équipe
[Applaudissements]